bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour décrypter
notre actualitté notre dossier du jour
est consacré au bizutage et à ses
dérives nous parlerons aussi du film
consacré à pierre kamat qui sort
aujourd'hui sur les écrans au cinéma
vous entendrez une inteview exclusive du
couturier qui a révolutionné la mode et
nous vous expliquerons pourquoi vous
regardez inattendu et vous êtes les
biens là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais
regarder la franche au fond des yeux
ligne j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en
apprennent à tricoter colle à votre
place la rame et non un peu moins et si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le tourmalet valable alors vous
l'avez certainement constaté les
événements prennent parfois leur source
dans le passé et il faut remonter le
temps pour mieux comprendre pour mieux
les comprendre
géraldine corner lavaud tariq al dit
bonjour vous êtes journaliste à la
rédaction dina vous avez décortiquer les
grands titres de la presse cette semaine
et deux sujets ont plus particulièrement
retenu votre attention
tarik comme beaucoup de personnes ce
week-end nous avaient été marqués par
cette image totalement incroyable
d'inserts chassé à courre qui trouvent
refuge sur un chantier après avoir fui
la forêt de compiègne cette image qui a
fait le tour de toute la presse et de
tous les médias je rappelle le principe
de la chasse à courre un qu'on appelle
aussi la vénerie alors les chasseurs
sont à cheval ils lâchent des chiens qui
est repères et traquent les proies
jusqu'à épuisement il ne reste plus qu'a
asséné le coup fatal à la bête cette
pratique il ya une discorde autour et ce
depuis déjà les années 70 mais l'archivé
nathanel que j'ai choisi de vous montrer
elle remonte à 1983
cette archive c'est une manifestation
devant le domicile d'un symbole de la
chasse à courre c'est monique de
rothschild la baronne de rothschild qui
ne s'est pas laissé impressionner elle
est même sorti pour débattre avec la
présidente de la spa de l'époque on
écoute
le chien courant a été je prends inventé
par le seigneur pour chasser les animaux
sauvages ces animaux sauvages ont que
vous le vouliez ou non des défendre ce
extraordinaire
heureusement pour un mais j'espère je
mets mais c'est toute l'attaqué mignon
mais on sait c'est le but de la vienne
riez d'avoir c'est un art madame
s'étonnant de voir les régulateurs les
gladiateurs c'était un art et puis ça
n'existe plus on n'est pas une identité
alala de la chasse contre le respect
animal le débat est loin d'être terminée
géraldine à tout autre sujet à attirer
votre attention
ça concerne la façon dont les lycéens
les lycéennes plus particulièrement les
lycéennes bien sûr ça me au sein des
établissements
oui 1 depuis la rentrée des témoignages
se multiplient sur les réseaux sociaux
pour dénoncer les remontrances de la
part des professeurs mais aussi des
proviseurs faite aux lycéennes sur leur
tenue avec le hashtag 14 septembre en
cause et bien des shorts trop court des
juges est elle aussi trop courtes des
crop top on laisse apparaître l'ombilic
bref le ministre de l'époque des crop
top des petites sommes qu'on laisse
apparaître le nombril ol l'ombilic le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer a réagi après avoir dit
dans un premier temps qu'il fallait
s'habiller normalement je cite lundi il
a déclaré sur rtl qu'il fallait venir
habillés de façon républicaine au lycée
alors bon qu'est ce que ça veut dire
s'habiller de façon républicaine
personnellement j'ai pas la réponse 1
mais ce que je sais c'est que ce n'est
pas la première fois que le style des
lycéennes dérange au sein des
établissements
aujourd'hui c'est donc le croque top qui
fait débat mais en 1960 nathanel eh bien
c'était la mini jupe et le blue jeans on
regarde je me rappelle que j'avais une
des lectrices surtout qui nous faisait
monter sur les 100 l'estrade et et avec
une règle venez mesure est
minutieusement la langueur des loges
louées de la jupe ou les jouets à par
terre quelle est la longueur
réglementaire
aubin c'est assez long mais bien au
dessous du genou henri beyle au dessus
du genou oui ils sont ou pas de jupe ans
parce qu'on pouvait banos cuisse alors
qu'est ce qu'on nous est interdite on
nous interdit les cheveux dans le dos
des cheveux décolorés le maquillage les
lunettes fumées
le sac à main les pantalons les collants
de couleurs le talent donc voilà un les
lycéennes libres de s'habiller comme
elles le veulent un long combat loin
d'être gagné un bon débat également
merci beaucoup géraldine alors ça
c'était pour l'actualité des derniers
jours mais sinon que s'est il passé le
23 septembre
ces dernières années c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé
1 23 septembre regardez
pour réaliser cette opération plein
d'avenir il a fallu un donneur
compatible extrême concentration dans la
salle d'opération c'est la première fois
qu'un membre d'un donneur est ainsi
greffé mais que je vois ça comme le
dernier né de la sncf le train corail
fonctionnera dès dimanche au départ de
lyon l'aménagement intérieur des
voitures étaient particulièrement
soignée tout possède climatisation et
sonorisation depuis 40 ans au pouvoir en
libye le colonel kadhafi va s'exprimer
pour la première fois dans l'hémicycle
de l'onu
il avait un quart d'heure son discours
va durer plus d'une heure trente
diatribe contre l'occident
brandissant le texte fondateur des
nations unies il s'en prend à la
domination des membres du conseil de
sécurité
avons nous le droit de veto nous les
petits pays
ça nous tous égaux comme c'est écrit ici
non c'est faux
nous n'acceptons pas et ne la
reconnaissons pas et de joindre le geste
à la parole
et pour la circonstance le ring
est devenu un radeau
[Applaudissements]
les chutes ont ici davantage d'être
rafraîchissante sa frêle silhouette
exprimé un langage qui toucher aussi
bien les petits que les grands marcel
marceau est mort à l'âge de 84 ans même
quand je sais que bon nombre est
classique maintenant qu'elle restera
dans le temps il faut toujours jouer
même si c'est la dix millième fois comme
si c'était la première fois ce soir et
demain
voilà pour notre zapping
on s'intéresse au dossier de la semaine
avec une tradition qui remonteraient au
moyen âge à l'époque les nouveaux
étudiants de l'université paris devait
passer un test de bienvenue avec leurs
aînés sous la surveillance de la bb
jaune
on les appelait les baies jaune depuis
le 19e siècle on parle de bizuths et de
bizutage mais le principe reste le même
et reste surtout propre aux universités
et aux grandes écoles des pratiques qui
se veulent à priori plutôt drôle
décontracté mais qui prennent parfois
une tournure grave voire dramatiques
comme il ya quelques jours un étudiant a
été retrouvé mort dans le lac de sourzac
c'est en corrèze il participait à son
week-end d'intégration
l'enquêté est en cours tarik ces rituels
s'accompagnent souvent d'humiliation et
parfois même de violence vous avez tout
résumé un appel tout ça c'est la recette
du bizutage est bien parfois ces
bizutages
il vire au drame je me suis penché sur
la presse ces cinq dernières années et
ces cinq dernières années j'ai compté
quatre décès liés à des bizutages
alors sans remonter au moyen-âge tariq à
l'origine le bizutage a priori c'est
quand même plutôt bon enfant
c'est plutôt bon enfant a vu d'archivés
en tout cas vous allez le voir on va
commencer avec une archive la plus
ancienne condé sur le sujet qui remonte
à 1930
c'est une archive des actualités
françaises ces fameux bulletin
d'information qui était diffusé au
cinéma à l'époque donc regarder c'est un
passage à l'eau et à la farine comme on
en voit encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
c'est plutôt bon enfant
on va faire un petit bond de 33 ans dans
le temps on va arriver en 1963 c'est un
peu plus sportif mais c'est toujours bon
enfant c'est quelques épreuves sportives
un peu de maquillage rien de bien
chant on note surtout des sourires dans
ses archives nationales autant avec le
temps les sourires s'estompe l'esprit du
bizutage se durcit il se durcit et on le
voit un an après leurs chiffres qu'on
vient de voir en 1964 l'émission 16
millions de jeunes s'est penché sur le
sujet au lycée stanislas de paris
pourquoi ce lycée nathanaël et bien tout
simplement parce que en 1964 il se dit
qu'un étudiant aurait été blessé à la
jambe après avoir été jeté du premier
étage alors à cette occasion les
journalistes sont allés sur place ils
ont discuté de la question du bizutage
avec les étudiants certains étaient déjà
un peu agacé par cette pratique
on les écoute tout de suite j'ai visité
une semaine et après ils sont très
sympathiques avec nous une gêne et les
choses pour lui tout âge des plantes pas
d'esprit solidarité enfin moi je pense
pas
j'estime que nos chats que chaque bijou
subi dans son coin puis c'est tout est
ce que vous avez fait comme les stages
manquant grand chose des trucs habituels
sa région
chanson le coulage est ce que c'est un
cul l'âge c'est tout le monde je sais le
cul l'âge la tonnelle ça vous parle je
n'ai pas fait beaucoup d'études ça me
dit rien je vous souhaite en tout cas
tant mieux si vous n'êtes pas passés par
là parce que c'est tout simplement une
pratique qui consiste à baisser le
pantalon d'un étudiant de le frapper à
coups de dictionnaires ou même un coup
de paillasson métallique sous prétexte
qu'il aurait mal parlé à un ancien ou
qu'il aurait tout simplement oublié les
chansons les paroles d'une chanson
paillarde alors excusez moi mais c'était
toléré tout ça par les chefs
d'établissement l'époque
oui et non alors officiellement le
discours s'est pas de bizutage en tout
cas pas de bizutage violent mais bien
évidemment les directeurs ne mettait pas
vraiment le nez dans ce qu'il se passait
à l'époque
d'autant que parfois ça va très bon ça
va très très loin même parfois en 1990
dans les années 90 notamment où on
recense les premiers morts officiels à
cette occasion une enquête à vous
proposer en archives date de 1991 c'est
un extrait du droit de savoir le droit
de savoir de magazines d'info diffusée
entre 1990 et 2008 qui en 1991 se penche
sur cette question du bizutage avec des
images très choc
on y voit des épreuves physiques encore
une fois mon niveau surtout de la
violence on y voit la consommation
excessive d'alcool on y voit également
dans la nudité de l'humiliation et
surtout un témoignage choc un ancien
étudiant vétérinaire un bleu comme on
les appelle ils nous expliquent ce qu'il
a subi on écoute tout de suite
bleu gens là étaient en première année
vétérinaire à amiens il y a quelques
années après l'épreuve de bizutage qui
les suit
il a quitté l'école enterré sa vocation
et s'est reconverti dans le professorat
de mathématiques
la plainte qu'il a déposée à l'époque
pour qu'on lui rende justice n'a jamais
abouti
comme toutes les plaintes de ce genre
aujourd'hui il se souvient avec émotion
ils ont arrosé d'un colorant qui l'avait
dit l'une en alcool à brûler pour que
soit disant de colorants tiennent mieux
qu'on ait plus de malades retiré puis
face à priori indépendant de la première
ils ont approché une bougie pour simuler
le marquage au fer rouge
j'ai déroulé au premier deuxième
troisième degré selon les endroits
survint concentration c'est vrai que
c'est c'est très violent pour autant
dans son commentaire le journaliste
explique ba qui a pas être déçu de suite
après le dépôt de plainte pas dessus du
désert tout simplement parce que à
l'époque
en 1991 il n'ya tout simplement pas de
loi pour punir les auteurs de bizutage
pour cela nathanel il faut attendre 1998
un projet de loi proposé par ségolène
royal elle expliquait son projet
quelques mois plus tôt à la rentrée 1997
on l'écouté on arrivera à cevital est
indiquée parce que le jour où les
auteurs de violence se rendront compte
qu'ils ne bénéficient plus des
l'impunité dont ils bénéficiaient
jusqu'à présent ça sera terminé et
depuis ben pour les auteurs de ce genre
de fait ces six mois de prison 7500
euros damende pourtant ça ne suffit pas
à faire disparaître le bizutage dyke non
pas du tout on va voir ça avec un
professeur engagée dans la lutte contre
le bizutage en 2007 en 2007 ça nous fait
neuf ans après la loi pour les coûte
tout de suite la loi de 98 a
certainement changer les choses mais a
poussé la discrétion plus qu'autre chose
avant c'était plus voyants c'est au
jardin du luxembourg c'était au château
de versailles
là ce n'est plus ce n'est plus à ces
endroits là c'est plus cacher et le tout
bien sûr avec un certain silence sur les
faits de la part des responsables
universitaires et peu de suites
judiciaires
merci beaucoup tarik l'actualité en
france aujourd'hui c'est aussi la sortie
du film pierre cardin un biopic sur ce
monstre sacré de la mode
une oeuvre qui nous touchent plus
particulièrement ici à l'inattendu car
les réalisateurs américain s'appuie sur
des archives pour retracer la vie de
pierre cardin est ce qui nous a encore
plus touchée est bien c'est que pierre
cardin accepté de nous recevoir pour
parler de sa carrière il est âgé de 98
ans nous lui avons présenté trois
archives qui correspondent à des moments
importants de sa vie
et regardez c'est la réaction dans la
mode j'ai réussi à réaliser et des
volumes des formes des matières des
couleurs
finissez pas cette année toutes les
couturières rêvait des cosmos
[Musique]
inquiétant lors de quatre envoyés par
l'ordinateur central dominé aussi par
ledit époque c'est la lune avec on
parlait beaucoup du cosmos
on parlait beaucoup de marché sur la
lune demain rien mais les cosmonautes y
avait c'est ce monde inaccessible
c'est une fascination pour moi de
réaliser un rêve que les red bull
toujours ça me fascine et de regarder la
lune
[Musique]
c'est une femme libre avant tout libre
de ses mouvements indépendante un mot
doit être demain et non pas être inspiré
d'hyères je cherche le fonctionnel le
pratiquent et le nouveau avant tout sa
rétrospective de la mode et résidente au
mode est un succès
[Musique]
le
le plus provocant on y croyait parle
c'est difficile d'arriver à des
passeports à kout rayon une silhouette
retient sa différence c'est un médium
qui me l'avait hama 20 ans lorsque je
dis davis shikin avait prédit que
j'aurai la une réussite exceptionnelle
et que mon nom serait dans le monde
entier même en australie
je voulais la voir le succès est gelé il
leur ne s'est pas produit si c'est
vraiment ce serait un peu dit oui je
voulais avoir du succès je voulais être
quelqu'un voulait de moi même
voilà un sol et voilà notre interview
réalisée dans le bureau de pierre cardin
invités de cet inattendu sophie de
champsavin bonsoir vous êtes rédactrice
en chef de paris match
c'est quoi le style cardin comment
s'inscrit le couturier dans l'histoire
de la bastille le cardan c'est un style
intemporel
c'est quelqu'un qui a vraiment créer un
nouveau langage un peu vestimentaire
basé sur la géométrie luron le carré
pour lui le rond c'est l infini il est
sûr voulu créer ce qui n'existait pas en
fait qu'elle a toujours rien pas un
petit peu en avant géraldine en
regardant attentivement dans les
archives de l'ina vous avez remarqué une
petite contradiction du créateur au
niveau du style
oui j'ai chercher la petite bête hein
est effectivement en 1964 il est sur le
plateau du journal télévisé de la rtf
avec un autre grand nom de la mode
française
andré courrèges et ils débattent et bien
du pantalon pour femmes
on en 64 ans je le répète et pour pierre
cardin et bien c'est tout simplement
inadmissible au regarde ce qu'on appelle
une femme à des hanches
n'est ce pas et un pantalon qui nous
loue même s'il ne moule pas ne rend pas
la femme esthétique ne la rend pas
sensuelle indiscutablement ou alors la
rend sensuelle mais d'une façon assez
vulgaire est-ce que vous avez remarqué
comment une femme vit en face d'un homme
elle ne peut pas s'asseoir elle peut pas
marcher aurait ou et la sensualité pour
vous
une femme doit plaire à l'homme qu'est
ce que vous entendez vous pensez que la
sensualité est fait d'un vêtement est
pourtant un six ans plus tard après
cette archive il présente une collection
où la femme est présente et donc comme
moderne libre de ses mouvements et elle
est bien en pantalon on le voit sur les
archives c'est des pantalons très près
du corps d'ailleurs sophie chang cervin
est ce que vous connaissez cette archive
avec courrèges et ce revirement un peu
sur la vision du corps de la femme
non cet échange entre les deux noms je
la connaissais pas c'est sympa de mars
ajustements mais c'est vrai qu'après il
a créé aussi des îles a utilisé un peu
des nouvelles matières dans lequel on
sen t bien du vinyle du plastique du
creps synthétique et je pense qu'il a
aussi créé pour la mode masculine
à l'origine c'était surtout en fait les
anglais les italiens qui avaient un peu
ce monopole de la mode masculine et il a
créé voilà il a mis en avant la mode
masculine en créant des jeux monsieur
d'aider des combinaisons pour pour les
hommes et en faisant défiler les hommes
et gagne en faisant défiler les sommes
exactes et voir exactement exactement
pierre cardin qui a participé aussi à la
démocratisation de la mode notamment en
organisant en 1959 le premier défilé de
prêt-à-porter
c'était dans un grand magasin le
printemps à paris est ce que ça a changé
beaucoup de choses
ma quelque part c'était faire descendre
la mode dans la rue donc c'était assez
novateur c'est un peu les prémices
effectivement du prêt-à-porter la
démocratisation comme vous aviez dire en
fait de de la mode c'était ça c'était
son envie aussi de deux voilà deux de se
faire aussi remarquer il aimait aussi
faim ils l'aiment
voilà l'audace il aime choquer quelque
part aussi et justement ça va choquer le
prêt-à-porter mais ce qui va encore plus
choqué c'est que rapidement après
l'industrie du prêt-à-porter
dès les années 70 il ya des reportages
intitulés lempire cardin c'était
vraiment le nom des sujets parce qu'il
vend sous licence son nom et ça ça a
choqué 1
alors au début c'est pour des chocolats
pour des parfums et c'était très
critique et ça aussi par ses pairs mais
ils se défendent et on les écoute mais
vous vendez votre nom
pour le chocolat pour les montres les
lunes c'est une garantie de prestige
estime que si je vends du chocolat bien
que non c'est parce que je suis trop le
chocolat est d'une grande qualité d'une
garantie de prestige ça rassure les gens
mais ça ne vous gêne pas votre nom soit
le signal ne venant pas de chocolat et
de la qualité france avec l'inde en la
parant de donner mon nom sur un chocolat
si justin qui est premier plan comme sur
le parfum chocolat parfum c'est du
prestige
enfin vous le désiriez aussi pour une
marque de lessive si c'était la
meilleure parade non pas la lessive
servant dans un c'est pas le cadeau moi
c'est plutôt le cadeau n'est ce pas qui
m'intéresse
alors très vite un vous savez les
produits sous licence pierre cardin vont
s'éloigner de ce que lui entendait à
cette époque-là par le prestige et le
cadeau alors bon il n'y a jamais eu de
lessive pierre cardin mais des skis des
vélos des briques et des blocs notes je
vous laisse écouter cet inventaire
miroir luminaires voilages papier peint
pendule vases sont aussi signé cardin
plus une cuisine dessiné par lui avec
wesseltoft fond vert couvert et ce
gadget salière poivrière beurrier
sucrier confiturier tout l'intérêt ce
jusqu'à la bicyclette au ski et à la
presse qui se fit chance là est ce que
finalement cette diversification ne l'a
pas un peu perdu
ça lui a permis aussi d'être indépendant
de faire ce qu'il voulait ne pas
appartenir un gros groupe
il a gagné beaucoup d'argent et de
gagner beaucoup d'argent c'est un homme
d'affaires aussi avant tout c'est un
créateur mais mais un brillant brillant
d'affaires c'est ton pire finalement
vous le disiez lui a permis d'être
indépendant il ya aujourd'hui beaucoup
de marques dont le propriétaire le
créateur reste reste le seul seul maître
à bord non très peu c'est un des seuls
effectivement grands couturiers
aujourd'hui à être indépendant et avoir
cette liberté en fait d'expression et à
tous niveaux dans la mode dans
l'ameublement dans la parfumerie un peu
partout comme on l'a vu sur ces archives
c'est vrai c'est quelque chose on n'a
pas monté dans le sujet mais
effectivement il
encore aujourd'hui à 80 18 ans il dit
qu'il n'a pas eu besoin de banquier et
il le répétera c'est assez intéressant
aussi cette vision là il aime dire aussi
en fait que on voyage on se nourrit on
boit on savent ni ans pierre cardin a
non pire estimé il ya quelques années à
un milliard d'euros
il n'a pas d'enfant que va-t-il se
passer lorsque pierre cardin va
disparaître alors il n'a pas d'enfant
mais il a il a une famille à des neveux
qui pour comprendront peut-être après la
succession
il a une équipe dans ses ateliers aussi
qui prendront la suite après peut-être
qu'un grand groupe s'intéressera aussi à
cenon dans tous les cas ce nom va rester
il est présent je crois dans 140 pays
à peu près les très représentés hier
internationale aux états unis en asie en
russie
donc son nom est très très très présents
un peu partout à l'international
allemand qui restera au vent tant que
spécialiste de la mode
si vous devez garder une chose de pire
car d'un vêtement c'est un vêtement
c'est sa robe sa robe bull en fait qui
l'a fait connaître qui est très
emblématique en date de son style de son
style cardin qui a été aussi porté par
emma peel je crois dans chapeau melon et
bottes de cuir voilà c'est ce style
vestimentaire en fait très très
intemporel voilà donc le film pierre
cardin qui sort aujourd'hui sur les
écrans et puis à noter la sortie il ya
quelques semaines d'un autre fils est
consacré à pierre cardin c'est un
documentaire cyril contre goliath qui
dénonce notamment l'investissement
réalisé par le couturier dans le village
de lacoste commune que pierre cardin est
accusée d'avoir dramatisé voilà deux
films qui sont différents mais très
intéressant tous les deux l'inattendu
touche à sa fin merci beaucoup
sophie de champsavin de nous avoir à
expliquer cette mode et ce style cardin
on se retrouve mercredi prochain à 21h
toujours sur le canal 27 et tous les
jours bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux
que ce soit ceux de l'ina ou ceux de
france info comme chaque semaine on se
quitte avec une petite pépite de la
télévision française
un voyage en 1973 en voiture avec la
chanteuse barbara elle tricote et
surtout elle fredonne du gainsbourg la
chanson de prévert c'est de se
cette chanson
[Musique]
m
on
et ce jour
joie mouvement
il
[Musique]
ok